two nights ago I flew to Phoenix to
challenge the New England Patriots Rob
Gronkowski and the Seattle Seahawks
Marshawn Lynch to play the not yet
released fighting game Mortal Kombat X
yeah yeah it was even it's not even
released yet that game it was a very
exciting night everyone wondering what
will happen who would win and really
wondering would Marshawn Lynch actually
speak would he say a single word ladies
and gentlemen
see for yourself in just a few days over
78,000 screaming fans will be gathered
here to cheer on the New England
Patriots and the Seattle Seahawks in the
ultimate football competition Super Bowl
xlix so I thought what better place to
record what might be our biggest and
most intense clueless gamer yet so I
asked University of Phoenix Stadium and
they said absolutely not so now we're in
the conference room of a nearby
Courtyard Marriott has free Wi-Fi and
smells faintly of foot power either way
it's game on Rob Gronkowski Titan New
England Patriots ak8 drop height 6 feet
6 inches bite strength 4,000 pounds per
square inch Marshawn Lynch running back
Seattle Seahawks 8 k 8 beast mode
favorite candy skittles favorite Gilmore
girl character gentlemen are you
familiar with this game when you play
Mortal Kombat before any of the versions
I played before yeah video arcade games
right
I'm wooden mashing for Shoto Oh USO show
yeah it's a technique like this that's
looking dirty all right stop it
you guys don't just just keep it clean
okay this is show primarily for children
don't know you guys are in my dojo now
and by dojo I mean the courtside
mariette somewhere in Arizona I don't
even know who are we gonna play which
guys do you want to be what you know to
cook though you know mo there's commando
he's the one that fights without
underwear Rob what do you want to be I'm
gonna be ferret or so Farah Thor is some
kind of a monster with a bag over his
head and then what is that on his back
that's my life coach right there oh
that's the one that test telling you you
could do it sing and pass on your resume
[Music]
all right here you guys go
yeah and I'm from Buffalo where are you
from it doesn't fit what's what you're
doing in other words here we go I'm
trying to oh that's good I get taken
into the oh there's gotta be a
League rule about that you win I push
you loving in the back with a puppet
Rick okay here we go Oh Maax less button
smash those buttons croc your head is so
big you can hit every button at the same
time Oh Martians as well travel be real
did you really feel
[Applause]
let's master an innocent dog tripping
right how did that feel that was too
much for you you couldn't handle it it
filled me with like a sexual thrill that
gave you a sexual thrill you are a sick
person yeah guys with your video game
backgrounds having played marshawn what
about you would you like to play Mario
Kart will you like my Mario Kart tow and
I'm like driving you like driving yeah
and you like to drive as toad yeah and
that's you driving easy pretty intense
that's how total do it right I probably
look more like don't ya house there and
I just come right over and run over you
you got to get a mushroom or a lightning
bolt yeah yeah a little first I know
that's why I be giving well I'm telling
my dad come over there love smash oof
oof oof oof
I don't know either one of you were
talking about it no way in the head okay
you just crushed my shoulder okay who's
who should we be Trixie
yes had a pearl fight okay so you're
Cassie cage yeah and you are Devore she
blew a bubble and she blew a bee
it's not cool she rock-a-bye baby dude
that's that new jack city foot Kronk
he's your bumblebees a stupid thing to
say
no one's ever said crunk use your
bumblebees lick the gun like the gun
like the gun lick the game again and I
feel your time are you going we don't
take the skittles
you might need to taste the rainbow
[Applause]
we won't be okay don't touch me for a
while that's horrifying he was talking
only about me just a minute ago and then
now I'm here in a fetal position you
might a little suck your band already
there now yes he listens to you
I think he's your you're smart I'm
okay Super Bowl has a halftime show I
thought we should have one as well
no obviously we don't have Katy Perry
but I think I'm the next best thing
fellas this is for you two three
[Music]
a mess and paid MORTAL KOMBAT they met
up on the field Marshawn and his nemesis
Gronk
both refused to yield refused to you oh
now I will play for I am the true master
I am scorpion and you are sub-zero and
Marshawn appreciate your help on this
okay what do you think dougie
that's the dougie right there I don't
know what you're talking about don't
trip it's all good why do you think he's
winning telling me not to trip out trip
when I got a trip
No
did I just do that no I did
do you mind because I just want is it
okay if I do sort of a touchdown move
you can do whatever you have a football
guys tell me what to do I just beat you
I can throw it off your face when you
score you got to hold your nuts like
this yeah yeah like that well you got a
jump in the air to put your hand in yeah
like that you know I know you get fine
when you do it but you're in a free zone
here I'm gonna fire free zone in fact I
will pay you $50 to do it just show me
how it's done so you you time it up yeah
it steps three steps yeah one two and on
the third step you here yeah what you do
is you come with it fall bad dang got to
be strength $50 that's for you
that's the league I play in you know
what you ain't got a score to grab your
nuts excuse me young fella you know say
you sit here wait for your turn on a
video game and just you won now we want
to see yo touchdown dance okay I'll show
you what I do okay there we go I catch
the pass right get it over the shoulder
it's still not in I'm coming in and I'm
taunting everyone behind me farewell
chums see you later alligator
talking right and then I crossed the
line right here okay then I take the
ball kiss it rock it to sleep put it to
bed
creep out I'm on Lipitor
that's my drug of choice lipitor get
yours today I get free money for hours
we're gonna score now I believe Marshawn
has the most victories today but I was
born and raised in Boston my family
lives there so I'm calling this a draw
gentlemen you can share this trophy it's
an almost exact replica of a Super Bowl
except in honor of Mortal Kombat it has
a severed head you guys get to share
this that's for both of you I know why
you gave really mature incredible
forget it Marshawn that's yours
[Applause]
you can see the other video games I've
reviewed a team koco.com slash clueless
gamer we got an amazing show tonight
[Applause]
you